no matter how hard you might try you
can't just flip a switch when you step
into the office and turn your emotions
off feeling feelings is part of being
human a pervasive myth exists that
emotions don't belong at work and this
often leads us to mistakenly equate
professionalism with being stoic or even
cold but research shows that in the
moments when our colleagues drop their
gloss be professional presentation we're
actually much more likely to believe
what they're telling us we feel
connected to the people around us we try
harder we perform better and we're just
generally kinder so it's about time that
we learn how to embrace emotion at work
now that's not to say you should
suddenly become a feelings fire hose a
line exists between sharing which builds
trust and over sharing which destroys it
if you suddenly let your feelings run
wild at work and give people far more
information than they bargained for you
make everyone around you uncomfortable
and you also undermine yourself you're
more likely to be seen as weak or
lacking self-awareness so great to say
you weren't feeling well last night you
don't need to go into every lower detail
about how you got reacquainted with your
half digested dinner so there's a wide
spectrum of emotional expression on one
hand you have under motors or people who
have a hard time talking about their
feelings and on the other end are /
motors those who constantly share
everything that's going on inside and
neither of these make for a healthy
workplace so what's the balance between
these two extremes it's something called
selective vulnerability selective
vulnerability is opening up while still
prioritizing stability and psychological
safety both for you and for your
colleagues
luckily anyone can learn to be
selectively vulnerable with practice
here are four ways to get started first
flag your feelings without becoming
emotionally leaky bad moods are
contagious and even if you're not
vocalizing what you're feeling chances
are your body language or your
expressions are a dead giveaway so if
you are crossing your arms or hammering
on your keep
your coworkers are going to know you're
upset and if you don't say anything they
might start to think it's about them and
get worried so if you are reacting to a
non-work-related event so traffic for
example just plug it you don't need to
go into detail you can say something as
simple as I'm having a bad morning it
has nothing to do with you
now if it's a work-related event that's
causing you to feel strong emotions that
brings us to point number two try to
understand the need behind your emotion
and then address that need if you
suddenly start to find everyone around
you irritating sit back and reflect on
that and it might be that you're
irritable because you're anxious and
you're anxious because you're worried
about hitting a looming deadline and in
that case you can go back to your team
to address that need and say something
like I want to make sure I get
everything done ahead of the deadline
can you help me put together a realistic
plan to do that if you're thinking of
sharing try and put yourself in the
other person's shoes so if what you're
about to say would help you feel more
supported and better understand a
situation then go ahead and share it but
if it gives you any kind of pause you
might want to leave it out and finally
read the room and provide a path forward
if everyone on your team has been
pulling long hours and you notice that
one of your colleagues seems
particularly deflated or anxious you can
acknowledge that and show some empathy
but then try to give them something
actionable that they can hold on to and
in this case you could suggest that you
go to your manager and ask that your
weekly meeting be pushed back a day so
you both have more time to work you're
showing that you're invested in their
success but also that you care about
their well-being when we can be honest
about what we feel and freely suggest
ideas make mistakes and just not have to
hide every piece of who we are we're
much more likely to stay at the company
for a long time
we're also happier and more productive
so take a moment to reflect on the
emotional expression that you bring to
work each day and if you are prone to
over sharing try editing and if you're a
little bit more reserved look at their
moments when you can open up to your
colleagues and be a
vulnerable and chances are there will be
a big difference in how people respond
to you and select a vulnerability might
just become one of your most valuable
tools
[Music]